So this is going to be a live recording,
well,
not alive,
a recording of our podcast before a live
audience.
These are the interns,
right,
of the American Enterprise Institute.
Senior staff.
We didn't actually invite them,
but they heard you were here and in
their way,
they just,
all,
we ended up in this room.
We were going to be at our dark studio.
Yeah,
no.
Well,
this is nice.
It's good to have.
It's nice to be in front of all your
people.
So hypothetically,
we'll see how civilized.
Sure.
Yes.
Is Antifa here?
No aunties.
No,
it's good.
Good.
All right.
So we ready?
Yeah,
it's really nice to see you.
So nice to see you.
Okay.
Start.
Go.
Welcome to the FAM.
Xplaners I'm Danielle crittendon and I'm
Christina Hoff summers and we are
thrilled to have the father of all
mansplainers in our studio today.
You know,
I think he's actually more of a man
whisperer.
Yes,
a man whisperer and the mad genius
behind the intellectual dark web,
whatever.
Welcome to the FIMS planers Jordan
Peterson.
Thank you very much.
So delighted to have you.
And it's an honor to have you honor and
a note to our listeners.
We're recording this in front of a live
audience at the American Enterprise
Institute in Washington DC where
Christina is a resident scholar and
there'll be video of the podcast as well
and we will let you know where to find
that when it's ready.
And we're also grateful to Aei every
week for the use of its recording studio
for the podcast.
And now for an introduction though he
needs no introduction to the people
here,
but Jordan Peterson is a professor at
the University of Toronto and author of
many books and and poster of many
fantastic lecturers and his most recent
book has,
I can't keep track of how many languages
it's been translated into and the sales.
Just a phenomenally successful book
tour.
In fact,
my first question is really about your
tour.
You look pretty good for somebody who's
visited what a hundred cities in the
past years,
January 23rd I don't know how you do it,
and mostly flying.
What do you do for fun?
What do you ever get to relax?
Even brief moments.
And what do you do?
Go on twitter and,
Oh God,
yes.
Although I've been qualified that is
relaxing.
Um,
I tried to forestall that temptation as
much as possible.
Well,
I have the auto mode bit of time that I
can spend with my wife.
She does travel with me.
And so,
you know,
we've had,
we,
we tried to take some time to walk
around the cities that we're in,
um,
and see what we can,
we're usually not at any given place for
more than a day or two.
And they're usually pretty packed up
with,
well,
whatever is associated with the lecture.
And then with press that the publishers
usually arrange.
Well I heard you interviewed in Sweden,
you were in Stockholm and you were,
had a,
had a half an hour to visit the city
with your wife.
Yeah.
And you loved it.
But that,
you know,
it's very tricky breaks where you get
them.
Well,
the thing is is that the,
the lecture to her is unbelievably
positive.
Yes.
And a lot of this has is ridiculously
positive.
You know,
like,
so if I'm going out on the streets now
or in cafes or you know,
airports,
I meet people all the time and they're
always polite and they're always happy
to see me and they always have some very
touching story to relate and,
and then the audiences themselves are
very positively predisposed to whatever
it is that we're doing together.
And so that makes it a lot easier to
stay motivated and to continue.
You know,
I mean it's demanding because
everything's scheduled so tightly and,
and I do a different lecture every
night,
every,
every time I go.
I find that amazing because I give a lot
of lectures that I anguish over
everywhere.
And then I have another one and it I it
you go up without notes.
Yeah.
Well I have a large collection of,
you know,
things that I know what,
how to talk about.
And usually what I try to do is to
formulate a problem before the lecture.
So I'm addressing a specific problem and
then I can track how I would set up the
argument and then I walked through it.
But part of it's also an attempt to
formulate the argument on the fly,
you know,
to,
to make the question,
what would you say to formulate it more
precisely and to make a more precise and
engaging answer.
And then I can use the audience to judge
whether or not that's,
that's happening.
And so it's also a real challenge to do
that.
So I enjoyed that and it's an excellent
intellectual workout and I've been
recording the lectures and I'd been
using fair some of them to write the
first draft of the chapters for my next
book and for books after that.
And so,
you know,
I'm,
I'm able to maximize the,
what would you say the utility of doing
this at each event.
And,
and my wife seems to be particularly
well suited to traveling like that.
She actually enjoys it quite a bit and,
and is very stable person.
And so,
um,
that's also helpful.
So,
uh,
and you know,
it's nice to have an extra brain along
because things are scheduled so tightly
that we don't ever have any room for
error.
Well we're going to,
I can't,
I don't know how intellectually rigorous
we plan to be with you today because we
know that when you ever year on one of
these platform,
you're talking about your ideas,
but on the fence planners,
we want to hear more,
a little bit more about Jordan Peterson,
the man desk desperately and definitely
want to hear about your wife Tammy.
And also you're so well known for your
views on men or how your ideas have been
taken up.
So enthusiastic or by young men.
But we want to talk to you about women.
Yep.
That's good.
So,
but what is it,
one of the things you and I share is
that we both grew up in Canada.
Um,
I promise Christine,
I would not do my Canadian accent while
you were here.
Um,
but you grew up in rural Alberta.
I grew up in Toronto.
Um,
and you are what?
The country's most famous grew now since
Marshall Mcluhan.
Um,
and uh,
but it's the fact that you came from
Canada have any effect on your views,
do you think,
has it formed you in any way?
I mean,
what did,
what would it,
would,
would it be the same if you think you'd
grown up in rural Texas?
How was Canada contributed to your
worldview?
She's always looking to,
for the Canadian angle?
Well,
I think the particular part of Canada I
grew up in probably was formative to
some degree.
I mean,
the town I grew up in was only 50 years
old,
you know,
and,
and the particular part of the world
that I grew up in was really the last
settled part of the North American
prairie.
This was outside of Edmonton,
correct?
Yeah,
about 400 miles north of Edmonton.
Oh,
400 miles.
Yeah.
It's right at the tip of the shorts.
So the prairie,
the prairie stretches up that far north.
It's stretches up farther north in
Alberta than it does anywhere else in
the North American continent.
And so we were at the tip of viable
farming essentially.
And so it was,
um,
it was a new place and it was a rather
raw place.
And it was,
it was a rather harsh place in many
ways,
especially because of the winter.
And it was fundamentally a working class
place,
although a prosperous working class
right.
Because most of the industry there was
related to the oil and gas industry on,
on.
Although it was cyclical,
when things were good working class
people could make a very good living.
This is during the 70s.
So through the goal.
Yeah,
that's right.
To be a kid in 400 miles outside a small
town,
but
liked it when I was a kid,
I wouldn't say it was as fun when I was
a teenager.
Um,
but I'm not convinced that,
you know,
the majority of people who are teenagers
necessarily have the most wonderful time
of it.
Um,
I think adults often look backwards at
the pass through rose colored glasses.
I think that's what the cartoon is
Trudeau accused Reagan of doing
continually.
Um,
Gary Trudeau,
the American Enterprise Institute tone.
Mister man.
No,
no man,
I'm getting input used for it.
In your book was teenage wasteland,
what you call it?
Yeah,
but it's Canadianness does,
do you,
how does that formed you or affected
you,
if at all?
Maybe it did.
It's hard to say.
I mean I've,
I've lived in lots of different parts of
Canada and Canada is quite different.
I lived in Alberta for a while and it
had this particular flavor of existence.
I mean,
mostly in fairview.
I was striving to leave and to move
ahead,
let's say,
or to move,
I hesitate to say up at somewhere
different somewhere more urban.
But that's the case with many people.
I mean the small towns all across the
West in the u s and Canada are dying.
They're down to nothing because
everyone's moved to the cities.
I lived in Montreal for a good while and
that was interesting because it was a
very,
very different culture.
Um,
it was a culture that was to some degree
stratified by language and by class.
None of that was true in Alberta because
it was so new that there's no class
structure.
Right.
So that was quite interesting.
And you worked,
um,
what I loved,
I pulled a passage because I think as
you say,
people are born in small places
everywhere and someone to leave and some
don't.
You said I want it to be elsewhere.
I wasn't the only one.
Everyone who eventually left the
fairview I grew up knew they were
leaving by the age of 12.
I knew.
And my wife who grew up with me on the
same street knew what was that thing,
what would you call that?
What's the thing that makes you want to
leave and,
and set you off because you point out
there was no class system education with
cheap in Canada compared to states.
It wasn't cost,
it was stopping people.
You were from a what?
Middleclass or you worked in other
words,
teacher and Mario and my mother was a
librarian though.
She had trained as a nurse.
So you know,
we had a comfortable,
I would say a suburban lifestyle
essentially,
you know,
um,
moderate,
middle class suburban lifestyle.
That's what trevor you looked like.
It looked like a surface hub that was
built mostly in the ninth save between
the 1950s in the 1970s.
So
the young Jordan and the then young
Tammy and you have to tell us that
story,
how you met but wanted one and more.
Well,
you know,
I think that's one thing that is
different to some degree about
class.
Um Hm.
My father and my mother had both left
the towns they were from and they were
forward future looking people.
And you know,
most of my friends who quit school and
who didn't attend university,
they didn't have,
they didn't have that sense.
I would say that more developed sense of
a world outside of what they knew.
And the other thing is that my,
my father took us on long trips when I
was a kid.
He was a teacher and so he had summer
holidays and we drove all over western
Canada and down into the u s long
driving trips,
thousands of miles.
And you know,
that also gave us the sense that the
world was a bigger place.
But I knew way before I was 12 I believe
that I was off at least to university.
And I think generally in your family,
if you're liable to go to university,
people don't even really talk about it.
It's just a given that that's what's
going to happen.
It's,
it's something that,
that you take in with every breath
almost.
It's,
it's an,
it's an often an unspoken expectation
and maybe people make casual reference
like,
well when you go to college,
but it's not like there's a question
about it.
Whereas if you're from a working class
background,
especially if your family hasn't pursued
postsecondary education that isn't in
the realm of unspoken or spoken
expectation.
And it wasn't like,
like lots of my friends,
including many of them who dropped out
before they hit high school,
they weren't by,
they were by no means the dumbest people
in the class.
Like they were plenty smart but they
weren't oriented towards the idea of,
of pursuing a career that,
that involved intellectual,
um,
what intellectual engagement wasn't in
their worldview.
And you know,
when you hear people on the,
let's say more socialists end of the
distribution,
talk about barriers to education,
they are often talk about cost and
sometimes cost is a barrier and,
and,
and it's more of a barrier.
Yeah.
And it's more of a barrier,
although there's still plenty of
community colleges,
state colleges where you can get
educated for a perfectly reasonable
amount of money.
But for my friends,
it was never a reason that money was
never a reason.
They didn't pursue post secondary
education.
It was more like a truncated view of
time,
I would say.
You know,
there was more of an emphasis on the
here and now and there were jobs aplenty
well there was also that,
yeah.
And,
and well paying jobs,
like it wasn't obvious that you were in
better shape economically to go to
university then.
Oh yeah.
Loss.
Especially if you were doing something
like working on the oil rates.
Right.
But,
but
you know,
that was rough,
cold,
harsh work and it wasn't,
it wasn't once you had an inn you could
stay employed,
but it wasn't that easy to land an entry
level job either.
And so,
mmm.
Yeah.
Well it was wise for lots of working
class people to,
to work in those jobs because they were
unbelievably lucrative.
So,
and they should have been because they
were very difficult and dangerous and
frigid cold.
And,
and,
and rough.
So,
you know,
it's not like the people didn't earn
your money.
Let's just tell us quickly how you met
your wife.
You were,
you met her when you were seven or eight
are in grade three and grade three yeah.
And you,
did you fall in love with her in grade
three and grade three and was it mutual?
Mm,
not in the beginning.
She wouldn't admit it if it was,
there were lots of the boys in grade
three.
We are in love with her.
She had a whole little crew of guys that
were perfectly willing to follow her
around and she was perfectly willing to
exploit that.
She was very good at it.
Yeah.
She was very popular and a little girl
so wonderful that you met his children.
They were friends for a long time.
You know,
we used to play chess together and
croquet and she was a vicious croquet
player.
She would,
I don't know if you've ever played
croquet,
but if it's your balls touch then you
can stand on European whack it and then
the other person's ball will vanish off
into the stratosphere.
She liked it,
knock it all the way down the street and
then she laughed.
No.
So she always had a good sense of good,
vicious sense of humor.
It's one of the things actually admire
about my wife when we're not,
when we've had our verbal disputes,
which you know of certainly happened.
She can string together a sequence of
insults.
That's so hair raising.
You have to laugh.
I was like,
did she have brothers?
Um,
she did.
She hasn't brother much older age,
eight years older.
Quite a peaceful person.
And she had two brothers to can get
along with guys,
guys,
guys.
Yeah.
They would,
they show love and affection by insults.
Yeah.
And Jabs and jeers and yeah,
and if you and I had brother and I
started learned,
okay,
I get it,
but if you don't have brothers,
girls like,
oh,
that's so rude.
That's so,
yeah.
So she was,
Well she,
she,
she has a,
naturally,
it was maybe a case,
she came by it naturally,
she should get
farther is,
uh,
quite sharp.
Witted and,
and,
and um,
well,
he was a real town character.
He's still alive,
Huh?
He was a real character and the tone in
real hyper extrovert,
everybody knew him and he had a pretty
good with torn him and she had some of
that while it still does have some of
that.
So she was uh,
you know,
aside from her acerbic yeah.
Humor and her ability to whack balls and
yeah.
I just don't want to go further on that
description and that could have many,
many things that tells us about you.
What else?
What else attract.
I mean,
you've known her pretty much your whole
life,
so some of the other qualities that not
just attracted you but enable you to
sustain.
I mean,
I think every young person in this room
will want to know,
and maybe there isn't one,
but what's the secret?
What's it like to be with someone that
long?
How do you sustain that?
You're fortunate.
Some of it's,
some of it's good fortune.
Um,
you know,
and I would say this is true.
I've watched people in the
relationships,
you know,
personally for a long time,
but also as a professional because I've
done a lot of clinical counseling and I
mean there's some things that need to be
a given about the relationship.
I would say.
Um,
it doesn't hurt to find the other person
very attractive,
you know?
And,
and that's a mysterious thing.
We're not exactly sure what it is that
produces,
let's say chemistry between people.
Although chemistry is definitely part of
what produces it.
There's subtle things that attract
people to one another that are way below
the level of consciousness.
So for example,
women don't like the older of men who
have rh blood factors,
who if they had children with would be
likely to produce a stillborn infant.
That's definitely a category of
match.com
well,
it's so strange though,
because you even know that's a good
question.
And you know,
you know,
by older apparently,
and so,
um,
there's all wearing cologne.
Well,
that then it would depend on what type
of colonias are h what was the smell is
a strange
sense.
And it's very deeply tied to very
profound emotions,
including memory.
And so you find people attractive for
reasons that you can't always determine.
And so,
so that,
that was part of it.
I mean I've always found her very
attractive in that continues and I liked
her combativeness you know,
like I think that there's,
you want someone,
I think in a relationship that you can
spar with and it's partly because you
have hard problems to solve and if the
person that you're with isn't willing to
put forward their opinion,
then you only have half the cognitive
power that you would otherwise have no
one.
Hopefully you find someone who's
interestingly different from you,
like not so different that you can't
communicate and you have to be careful
of that.
But interestingly different.
And then hopefully they have the ability
and the will to express their opinion
and then all,
then it's,
you know,
then then your interest stays heightened
and there has to be that tension in a
relationship.
You know,
people think,
well I want to get along perfectly with
my partner.
It's like,
no,
you,
you probably don't.
You just get bored.
And then you'd go looking for trouble.
And so you want it a little bit of
trouble in the relationship and a little
bit of mystery and a little bit of
combativeness and,
and the ability to exchange opinions
forthrightly and,
and I trust her,
which is a huge element.
I mean,
when,
when we finally did decide to get
together permanently,
we're both in our later twenties.
And you know,
one of the things that I had learned by
that point and insisted to her about was
that we had to tell each other the truth
and she took to that wholeheartedly,
you know?
And um,
for better and for worse,
because truths can be harsh.
Does that include like,
does this,
how fit?
Yeah.
Well,
the truthful answer to that is I don't
answer questions that are likely to get
me in trouble.
Yeah.
So I have a son who will answer
honestly,
and it's infuriating.
But then I realized if you want the
truth,
talk to Tamworth telling you,
well,
that's the thing,
you know,
it's,
it's useful to know truth is empowering
truth.
Tellers are charismatic and he never
actually,
both my sons are like brutally honest,
which is disconcerting.
Yeah.
But it's,
I can see that it has made them very
formidable.
And,
and because of the people trust them and
the friendships and just,
it gives them a,
and you've written a lot about that.
Well,
you know,
if,
if I tell my wife that she looks good in
that outfit,
she knows that I mean it.
Yeah.
And so there's some utility.
And then if you're silent and say,
I don't answer questions that she,
she goes and change,
well sometimes sometimes know,
she'll say,
you know,
do you like this?
And I'll tell her that I don't,
you know,
and that doesn't necessarily make her
happy in the moment,
but,
um,
but if I do say,
I like it,
she knows that I mean in,
and you know,
I actually liked her sense of style a
lot.
So it turns out that 90% of the time
it's pretty easy for me to say,
look,
I think you look great and mean it.
And,
uh,
you know,
she's a fairly harsh standard bearer to
like,
she's,
she's insisted that I stay in whatever
reasonable physical shape I happen to be
in.
You know,
that was,
that was something that she's very
demanding of it.
I would say that it's the same from my
side and um,
and we've been good at negotiating,
which is,
you know,
what do you want from a partner?
Fundamentally?
What,
what do you want need,
I mean the first thing is,
is that we'll hopefully you,
like I said,
you're blessed with the fact that you
find each other attractive and I think
it's very difficult for the relationship
to begin or proceed or sustain itself
without that.
But having that,
then what do you want while you want
someone that you can trust,
do you want someone that you can build a
view of the future with and you want
someone that you can negotiate with?
And that's very hard to negotiate with
people because they have to tell you
what they think.
They have to know what they want or
figure it out.
They have to tell you what they want.
They have to be satisfied when they get
what they want,
which is also a very difficult thing to
manage.
And you have to continually update that
because your life goes through different
stages and well in your attraction.
Wayne's,
as we all know at our stage of like not
Badaliya necessarily player's health,
but,
but no,
but you will go,
I mean you will not be 25 forever,
so,
so that that has to be renegotiated.
Yeah,
well then you have to work at that too.
Right?
You know,
and,
and that's something that people also
don't understand because they tend to
think that well that that all romantic
interaction should be spontaneous.
It's like,
well,
if that's your theory,
then you might as well just give up
right now if you're going to get married
because that like the only reason you
can think that is because you don't have
enough responsibility to make romantic
entanglement virtually impossible.
And what happens when you're married,
especially when you have little kids,
is that,
and you both have a job,
let's say,
is you're so busy that the probability
that you're going to find time for
spontaneous mutual interaction is
decreases to zero.
And so if that's what you're hoping for,
then you're never going to have it.
And so what you have to do is you have
to make time for each other.
And you know,
if you're dating,
um,
when you're establishing a relationship,
while you put some effort into it,
you know,
you,
you decide that you're going to go out
for dinner and you dress up to some
degree and you know,
you try to present yourself to each
other in some halfways mutually
acceptable manner and you hope that
there's going to be a positive
consequence of that,
that you're going to find each other
attractive.
But then as people somehow think that
once they're married,
that the same amount of effort isn't
necessary.
And that's wrong.
I would say more effort is necessary on
the same front and you have to think it
through.
It's like,
you know,
if you don't want to be bitter about the
intimate element of your relationship,
how much time do you have to spend
together each week?
And My,
my rule of thumb,
sort of derived from clinical
observations is that you need to spend
90 minutes a week with your partner
talking.
And that means you're telling each other
about your life and staying in touch,
you know,
so that you each know what the other is
up to and you're discussing what needs
to be done to keep the household running
smoothly.
And you're laying out some mutually
acceptable vision of how the next week
or the next months are going to go
together.
Right.
So that,
that keeps your narratives locked
together.
Like,
uh,
like the strands in a rope,
you need that for 90 minutes or you
drift apart and you need to spend
intimate time together at least once a
week and probably more like twice.
And that has to be negotiated.
And if you don't negotiate it,
and if you don't make it a priority,
then it won't happen in all likelihood.
And then,
well,
well then you don't have it.
That's a catastrophe because there's not
that many things in life that are,
you know,
intrinsically,
what would you say?
Engaging in meaningful and pleasurable
and also bonding,
all of that.
And if you let that go,
then well part of you dies and part of
the relationship dies.
And while then there's always the
possibility of becoming attracted by
alternative entanglement,
which,
which you would do if you had any spirit
left.
Right?
I mean that's the thing is if you're
not,
if you're,
if your relationship at home is entirely
unsatisfying sexually,
what are you supposed to do with that?
Nothing.
He was supposed to just bear it.
I mean,
in one way the answer is yes because
it's your marriage,
but another way as well,
what,
that's all the fight you've got in you.
You're going to just let the erotic
element of your life die and accept
everything that goes along with that
because you're not willing to causing a
bit of trouble to ensure that it's
maintained.
And you know,
and we're not very good at thinking
these things through consciously and it,
I mean,
people are bad at negotiating period.
As far as I can tell,
but they're particularly bad.
It negotiating things that are deeply
private.
How much do you want your partner to
know about you anyways,
it takes a lot of trust to have a real
conversation about what you need and
want.
Now you have it in the press.
People read that you are,
uh,
you have a following of young men.
And I went to hear your lecture in
Washington DC and there were a lot of
women there and your book,
I am,
first of all,
men don't buy books that often compared
to women.
So I'm presuming you have a lot of
female readers.
And I found it,
Jay,
Danielle,
and I found it completely readable.
And it wasn't a ribbon for men.
No,
it was one.
So you have more like a delusional
desire on the part of the radical
leftists that the only people that could
possibly be attracted to me or angry
men.
Exactly.
It'd be better if they were angry young
white men,
you know,
because then that fits the narrative.
But you have a diverse audience,
a diverse following,
including many women.
And they're also not particularly angry.
I mean,
I've talked to 200 fusing the anchor.
That's the point of your book is
stopping angry,
stomping,
resent.
All right,
well,
resentment is that that's absolutely
crippling,
right?
Get resentment.
Just zenman deceit,
arrogance.
That's part of,
I'm writing another book and one of the
rules is don't allow yourself to become
resentful,
deceitful,
and arrogant or those two things
together.
But it could be red.
Right?
Well,
that's supposed to be a good thing.
So yeah,
there's been 250,000
people,
as I said,
come to the lectures and there hasn't
been a single negative incident.
Not One.
This is what I find fascinating is that
I found you early on.
I said I had no idea you were just that.
It was like butch cassidy and the
Sundance kid.
Like who is that guy?
Who is that guy?
Like you were pretty good.
And we were covering a lot of the same
topics later on.
Yeah.
Wow.
And then,
you know,
I found out who you were.
What is astonishing to me is that
there's this amazing,
it just split between the positivity of
your audience and diversity of your
audience,
the,
the intellectual content of your
message.
And then you get with a snarky
journalist with an agenda,
and I'm not mentioning names,
but this,
no,
maybe no,
this,
this young woman from Gq and it was just
me on site and I'd say,
and it was just like few lady.
Gotcha.
For,
we didn't want to blame the BBC,
it was two or a saint and then I,
and she seemed,
you know,
like as often she seemed intelligent and
capable of insight up to a point.
But it's almost as if something gets
seized her mind and show you something,
had something happen.
I think people enjoy the meal.
Polyols it.
Can you a Polya says that a whole
generation,
some of our most talented young women
are incapable because of this idea.
Maybe you mean,
or just an openness to,
she couldn't,
and you were saying completely like
interesting,
fascinating,
original things even to me who've
studied these topics and wow.
And
No,
it was quite the day.
So I went to Baltimore.
You survived.
It made me think a lot that day because
I went there and I have to go out of my
way to do it.
Not that I'm complaining,
but there's a reason for saying that,
you know,
so I go up there in Baltimore.
Yeah,
well I was talking in Baltimore.
Oh,
okay.
So where's the aquarium?
And I showed up to the,
to the hotel room where this was all
occurring.
And you know what you expect,
generally speaking,
even from journalists who aren't,
you know,
who are more of the attack dog variety
or who may be,
aren't positively predisposed to
ideologically or personally,
you expect a certain modicum of
professional politeness.
Right.
You know,
because,
well,
you don't have to be there.
And you came and you accepted an
invitation and all of that.
And so even with the channel for
journalists,
Kathy Newman,
um,
she was quite polite and,
and forthcoming in the,
in the green room before the interview.
So she would have had at least that
professional persona,
which is,
it's not nothing right there.
There's something to be said for,
for going through the motions
professionally in an inappropriate
manner.
But when I walked into the hotel room in
Baltimore,
it was obvious that this interviewer had
already made up her mind about me 100%
and that she was absolutely,
you know,
negatively predisposed to me with a
personal animus.
Animus is exactly the right word.
And there was about a half an hour
photography session because it was Gq.
And so I was in that atmosphere.
The photographers were fine.
I was in that atmosphere for about 45
minutes before we started to talk.
And part of the reason that I'm so,
uh,
I'm not as calm during that interview is
I usually am,
I'm a little bit harsher.
And the reason for that is that,
you know,
it just started off instantly combative
and,
and what I,
what I should have done,
you see,
it's very,
very difficult to be awake enough to do
these things properly and to end the
interview progressed fine.
Although by the end of it,
I thought that I had maybe done enough
interviews for a while because I didn't
think I had regulated my temper as well
during that interview as I might've,
I was harsh.
Good.
Well for the first two minutes,
so you were getting at and then she
brought up a question about anger and I
just saw you kind of adjust and then
after that it was smooth.
Well that's good because it was touch
and go,
you know,
and I thought,
boy,
you know,
maybe you're running out of patients,
maybe you,
you know,
maybe it's time to dial back on the
interviews because you know,
I've had many interviews like that and
they're very,
I find them like,
and it takes me like three days to weeks
and then you start thinking of yourself
like what I should have said,
I should have said that and I drive
myself mad.
No,
but you did very well.
But it's so interesting that what it
told me was how parochial she was and
she lives in her own little world and
Stina isn't that more a little bit about
the ideology of our time and Gosh,
you encountered this everywhere.
And when I used to write about this
wisely,
I would,
I would encounter it.
I mean,
I think part of the issue is that you
will acknowledge that there are
differences between the sexes.
That seems to be,
I know that's a hell of a no,
that's a heresy because when I was
reading your book,
um,
there's nothing about it that is anti
female affecting you.
You do a lot of examination of the Adam
and Eve story and you have this
wonderful passage about like,
um,
Adam being the originally aggrieved man
who
throws the woman under the bus.
The original fault you made her.
I'm hiding.
That's really funny.
So,
so,
so there's nothing in there
and,
and the,
the rules such as they are,
you know,
they seem very common sensical.
They could apply to anyone.
Um,
so is that a fair surmise of why you get
so attacked?
Uh,
that just the very fact that you're
willing to speak about the sexes as
being not unequal but different.
Funny.
Cool.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
I would say that that's part of it
because there's a threat there.
So one of the things that happen when I
was in Scandinavia,
I just wrote a column about this
actually,
um,
was interesting being in Scandinavia,
especially in Sweden because they've
pushed the equality of opportunity
doctrine farther than any other country.
They invented it.
It almost started there like in the UN
and the original,
you know,
the charter,
the Swedes were there and they,
they've never given
no,
no.
And so,
and the week that I was there was the
same week that two articles were
published on gender differences,
um,
in,
in temperament and in interest.
And the biggest sex differences that we
know of that aren't morphological are in
interest.
So women are more interested in people
by and large and men are more interested
in things by and large.
And the difference is actually large.
It's one standard deviation.
And so that means if you're a man,
you would have to be more interested in
people than 85% of men to be as
interested as 50% of women.
And if you're a woman,
you'd have to be more interested in
things than 85% of women to be as
interested as the 50th percentile male.
So the difference is actually quite
substantial and it's certainly large
enough to drive occupational choice
differences,
which is does it explains a lot about
the configuration of people in the
workplace?
Absolutely.
Well,
and you know,
we're approaching approaching parody in
terms of workplace overall workplace
distribution of men and women,
but there's massive differences in
occupational choice.
Like it's very interesting,
for example,
to go to the website of the u s labor
department and look at male and female
dominated industries.
And you know,
there's the top 10 male dominated
industries have basically zero women in
them.
People,
brick layers like
people.
There are people free zones according to
Camille Paglia that you find you're just
a lot of men in the people free zones.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And the women are in ask a group of
women
and men,
would you rather spend the next three
weeks taking a part of machine and
putting it together or helping a group
of people work out their problems and
the pool of people who want to do them.
It's just far more men than women.
There's more men and women dominated
industries than there are women and men
dominated industries at the extreme.
So that's,
would that be like nursing?
Nursing is way more male nurses.
The male nurses,
I've studied these male nurses and they
already,
uh,
you know,
gender activists are upset because they
earn more than women.
And,
uh,
a professor of nursing at University of
Pennsylvania tried to find out why and
she found out they immediately find out
what's the best paying field subfield.
So they go into like nurse
anesthesiology,
it pays a lot more than men are there
and disproportionate number.
And they're willing to work and cry,
you know,
insane hours.
They're far more willing to move to a
higher,
same thing.
Farrell phone with,
with gender differences is that men are
more willing to move.
Maybe they're more willing.
We're willing to call me yours.
They're more willing to to uh,
work outside.
They're more willing to take on
dangerous tasks.
They're more likely to work in scalable
industries.
So we'd like,
you can't scale personal care.
It's really,
it's very,
very difficult.
They're much less likely to work part
time.
If they have small businesses,
they're much more likely to work full
time in the small business rather than
this than part time.
And I mean women have the reasons to
want to work part time and feral also
pointed out that if you work 10% longer
hours,
you make 40% more money.
A non linear nonlinear return on
overtime had something that's really
useful to know in terms of your career
to an employer that have somewhat also
marks you out.
You know,
like if you have 10 employees and
they're all doing a reasonable job,
let's say,
but one of them is working an extra half
an hour a day or 45 minutes a day and
you can observe that every day,
then that gives them an edge with
regards to potential promotion.
And so,
and the return on those edges is
nonlinear.
And so anyways,
so I went to Scandinavia and it was the
same week that two studies were released
showing what had already been
established beyond a shadow of a doubt
that the personality differences between
men and women and the differences in
interest as well actually get bigger as
your society gets richer and as it gets
more egalitarian and,
and not just a little bit either.
That's the other thing that's so
interesting is you might think,
well the effect is it's the opposite of
what the social constructionists would
predict first of all.
So that's the first thing to point out
is it's not only that their hypothesis
wasn't supported,
it was decidedly refuted and,
and none of them have come to terms with
that.
And,
and,
and it's not a small effect.
The,
the difference between personality
between men and women in Scandinavia is
a lot larger than it is in Noni.
Galitary and contract can rural Botswana
true in the United States.
The richer the democratic your household
demographic,
your household,
the more likely the woman to take
town timeout and be at home with the
kid.
Right?
Because she can afford,
she can afford to do it and she can
afford to major in odd,
you know,
low paying fields like a,
I don't know,
feminists dance therapy
you use,
you see to,
one of the things that's also
interesting I think is that,
you know,
there's this idea that mate,
that marriage is a patriarchal
institution,
you know,
that's primarily put there for the,
for the utility of the,
of the mail and think,
well like I think that's complete bloody
rubbish.
And I don't think there's any evidence
to support it at all.
But I think the best counter evidence is
that,
well,
if that's the case,
then rich people shouldn't be getting
married because they don't have to
oppress themselves.
But the truth of the matter is,
is that the higher your demographic
position,
the more likely you are to be married.
So marriage has fallen apart among,
you know,
in the more likely the wife is staying
home and not,
I mean,
she has all sorts of pursuits,
but she's not well,
there's an old saying,
anyone,
any woman who marries for money earns
it.
Um,
but now let me just,
okay.
This is where you might get in a little
trouble because in your book you call
men order and women chaos and you say
order,
the known appears symbolically
associated with masculinity and chaos.
The Eternal Feminine is also the
crushing force of sexual selection.
Yeah.
What's up with that?
We chaotic chaos.
Men and women,
order and chaos.
It's masculinity and femininity
symbolically.
And so what's happened fundamentally is
that we're,
our brains are wired for social
cognition.
So we're not natural scientists were
natural sociologists.
That might be a better,
even though I shutter to think that that
might be true,
especially given the stage associates as
well.
That's it.
Okay.
Triggering or maybe rick or,
or may him or maybe we're more,
we're more naturally,
uh,
people who observe through the lens of
fiction and that what we see as the
world as characterized and the world,
obviously it's made out of men and women
and children and those seem to be our
fundamental cognitive categories.
Masculinity,
femininity and,
and,
and then the category of children and
those categories have expanded to take
on connotations outside of,
of pure person perception.
And so,
you know,
it's for this reason that if you go to a
movie and then maybe it's a Disney
animated movie and I like to talk about
those because they draw on a very deep
symbolic,
well it's perfectly reasonable to see a
witch that lives in a swamp because
those go together.
Like it makes sense.
You know,
the which doesn't live in a gleaming
chrome high rise,
you know,
she lives in a swamp cause that's a
maybe an a shock for her room.
I think she could just fly up.
Well that's it.
That's where the high rise would be
better for the brand.
We can take off if you could take off
better.
But there are categories of,
of symbolic association that are natural
to the way we think.
And the fundamental elements of those
categories seem to be gendered.
And so this is partly why I make
reference to Taoism,
for example.
So for the Dow is the world is made out
of chaos and order and chaos is the
domain that you don't understand.
And that emerges unpredictably but also
the domain from which new forms emerge,
right?
Because it's from novelty that the new
emerges.
And I think the fundamental association
between femininity,
it chaos is the association between
what's unexpected and novel and what's
new.
Because new forms emerge from chaos.
And it's not that chaos is,
is bad in order is good.
That that's,
yeah,
no,
both have their pathologies.
Both have their pathology.
Yes.
And,
and,
and what you're looking for,
and this is,
this is the book concentrates on above
all,
is that you're looking constantly to
find the balance between those two.
So,
for example,
formerly speaking,
the domain of order is that place that
you are with.
What you're doing is producing the
results that you want,
who have produced.
So imagine,
imagine you think about the
preconditions for not being anxious.
Okay?
So the preconditions are that you're
constantly making predictions about
what's going to happen next.
And those predictions are tied tightly
to your behavioral output.
So you act in a certain way and you
presume that a certain thing is going to
happen.
And if your actions produced the results
that you desire,
then you assume that you know where you
are and you know what you're doing and
that your plan is intact and that the
environment is secure and that keeps
your anxiety under control.
That's order.
And then you know,
maybe you're at a party and you don't
know anybody and you tell a joke and
everybody looks at you like what you
said was not only not funny,
but also downright offensive.
And then all of a sudden you've moved
from the domain of order into the domain
of chaos because you thought you were
somewhere and you thought you were
someone.
And you thought you were with people
that were of a certain type and you got
all that wrong.
And so it causes the guessing is going
to be the woman who says,
I find that really open.
I'm not suggesting that it probably is,
nevermind,
but women are also more sensitive to
negative emotion,
right?
So there is some slightly higher
probability that that might be the case.
But then I think women are also
associated,
at least in men's imaginations with
nature,
which is part of the chaotic domain say
as opposed to culture because they're
sexually selective.
So you gotta think what?
What is nature?
When we have that as a cognitive
category,
right?
We think of the natural world,
we think of nature versus culture.
It's a fundamental opposition.
What is nature?
Well,
nature is trees and landscapes and
animals and all of that.
But that isn't what nature fundamentally
is.
Nature fundamentally is that which
selects from a genetic perspective,
that's nature.
That's the fundamental definition of
nature.
And it is the case that human females
are sexually selective and it's,
it's a major component of human
behavior.
So the,
the evolutionary theory,
roughly speaking,
is that the reason we diverged from
chimpanzees 8 million years ago,
7 million years ago,
is at least in part because of the
differences between sexual selectively
between female humans and female
chimpanzees.
Female chimpanzees are more likely to
have offspring from dominant males,
but it's not because of their sexual
selectivities.
So a female chimpanzee has periods of
fertility that are marked by physical,
uh,
by observable physiological changes,
not the case with human females.
Human female ovulation is,
is concealed.
So that's a very profound biological
difference between human females and
chimpanzees.
And the chimpanzee females will mate
with any male,
but the dominant males chased the
subordinate males away.
But human females are sexually
selective.
And so,
and it's not a trivial fact.
So you have twice as many female
ancestors as male ancestors.
You think,
well,
how can that be?
Well,
imagine that on average,
every single human female has had one
child throughout the entire course of
history,
which is approximately correct by the
way.
Then imagine that half of the men had
zero and the other half had to.
Okay.
And that's roughly the case.
So half of males historically speaking,
have been reproductive disasters.
And the reason for that is because of
female sexual subjectivity.
So it is actually the case that female
humans are nature.
It's not only that they're,
that they're associated with nature
symbolically as far as rep production is
concerned.
They are the force of nature that does
the selection.
And so their nature in the most
fundamental way,
and there is a chaotic element of that
at least in relationship to men and also
in relationship to women.
Because a lot of the um,
female on female competition is
competition.
That's chaotic for the right to be
sexually selective,
right?
Not only with regards to men,
which drives a lot of politicking but
also in relationship to each other
because part of what human females do,
his jockey for position in the female
dominance hierarchy for the top
position,
which is the woman who gets to be most
sexually selective.
And so that drives female female
competition.
And it's a different dynamic.
There's,
there's similarities between female
female competition and male male
competition.
But there are also differences and
they're pronounced.
So men,
for example,
are,
well,
men are more likely to compete,
compete for socioeconomic status.
And that's partly because that drives
female mate choice.
So the correlation for men between
socioeconomic status and sexual success
is about 0.6.
And for women it's zero,
zero,
in fact,
it's actually slightly negative.
So,
and that's a huge difference.
Men and women.
But do you know that?
Do you know the anthropologists?
Sarah Hrdy,
h,
r,
d y,
and,
and she's like my favorite feminist
theorist,
although she would say I'm a theorist
who happens to be a feminist,
but she studied primate behavior and she
watched,
she looked at the women very care.
They're the females in not with walking
very carefully and looked at it,
uh,
chimpanzees and gazelles and,
and found that,
um,
the female initially like male
primatologist would look and say,
oh,
the females,
the males are dominant and the females
are so cooperative.
She looked more carefully.
And so the females weren't exactly
cooperative.
Like they would pass around their
infants,
their baby,
you know,
whatever they were and would find it.
And so the male primatology will say,
oh,
they're,
they're so kind.
And caring.
She found out that when it was not your,
it was not hers,
they would take like little tufts of
hair,
you know,
it would come out or they do something
to the eyes,
you and the baby would like be injured
and she saw all this violence.
That would be true in her status.
Differentiation.
Yes.
It's much more likely that it'll happen
when a higher status female is taking
care of lower status infant.
Exactly.
And she said the great tragedy,
well not tragedy,
she had the reality of our species and
in fact the subtitle for the book is
that the woman who never evolved,
we didn't evolve for niceness and
cooperative.
There's immense competition and we can,
according to her,
we are,
it's indelibly marked in our nature to
compete for the dominant males and no
doubt about that.
There's so,
and that seems to cross culturally as
well.
That does flatten out a little bit in
the morning,
Gail,
the tarion societies.
Yeah.
So instead of being exaggerated,
it does flatten to some degree.
Right?
So you could imagine that there's a
biological component and the cultural
component of course,
both in,
in,
in that case,
if you modify the cultural component
then that seems to decrease the overall.
So like,
let me meet,
be more clear about this.
Women are less prone to mate up across
an up status hierarchies in Scandinavia
than they are in lessie Galitary and
countries.
But there are still prone to do it.
So worldwide for example,
women,
young women find men who are about four
years older than them maximumly
attractive and they tend to mate across
and up status hierarchies.
And so one of the consequences of that,
for example,
is that as women have entered the
workforce,
they've have actually driven in equality
because rich women will only marry rich
men.
Men rich as them or Richard.
Whereas rich men will marry women who
are poor than them,
but women won't.
And so what that means is it's another
factor that's pooling wealth in the
hands of fewer and fewer people.
This is all its assorted of mating know
and you just find someone with your
background here.
Whereas the doctor might have married
his secretary.
You now marries another doctor.
Yep.
Well,
can I ask then stepping a little bit
back from primates as well,
how does this um,
selection work in the era of swiping
right
and unless
how,
what is your reaction to the way young
people did
today?
Oh,
that's a good,
I was really hoping we'd get into that.
I was really,
you were very into the monkey so I
didn't want to interrupt.
No.
Well I should close off to Scandinavia
discussion just by pointing out,
and this is something that the
scandinavians are already going to have
to wrestle with,
is that if you institute effective
policies to promote equality of
opportunity,
which the Scandinavians have done,
you're going to produce some equality.
So like a 50 50 distribution of men and
women in the workplace,
but you're also going to exacerbate
certain kinds of inequality and you
can't get out of that.
So you cannot have equality of
opportunity and equality of outcome
together.
They don't work together.
And equality of outcome,
the essentially quality of outcome
doctrine,
which is often described with the code
word equity,
is that at every level of every
occupation,
the people have to be represented by the
same number that they're represented in
at the population.
So if it's not 50 50 men and women at
each in each occupation I need,
and in each strata at each occupation,
then that sort of prime of Fossi
evidence for discrimination and for
systemic discrimination,
it's like,
no,
sorry,
you have to factor in choice.
And choice actually turns out to be a
very important determinant.
And as the society gets flatter and
flatter,
choice becomes a more important and more
and more important determinant.
And so you,
so what that essentially means is that
the most radical end of the left wing
political agenda is logically
impossible.
Apart from the fact that it's impossible
for a variety of other reasons.
And they should look at the data.
I mean it,
it's just a cliche now of in any group
of activists and they'll say,
oh well we need to,
in order for women to achieve the
quality,
we need government funded daycare and we
need,
they have it in Sweden.
Sweden has fewer women in managerial
levels in American women are ahead.
In fact now they have jen,
oh they have quotas over there so they
need a female ceos and females on boards
and made any differences in bringing in
member American women because we're so
much further ahead.
Yeah.
It's called no difference in the
distribution of men and women lower in
the herd.
It's called the Nordic paradox and say
you guys are so wonky.
I want to get back.
Okay.
You all want to get back to,
I want to get back to those monkeys.
Well thinking
this morning about,
I was talking to a variety of political
types and we were talking about this
morning.
Yeah.
In DC and hard to believe.
Hard to believe.
No I'm not.
I'm not telling you.
Okay.
Bunch of Republicans here.
And I've been talking to Democrats as
well,
but it was mostly Republicans here.
And we were talking about abortion and
um,
I made a case that that's really not a
very productive discussion because
you're talking about a problem way too
late in the sequence of problems.
So,
um,
by the time the discussion starts to be
about abortion,
there's 50 problems that have already
emerged that no one has addressed.
And some of those problems are the
fundamental problem is how human beings
should regulate their sexual behavior.
And that's a big problem.
And you think,
well,
there's an interesting thing that's
happening because you know,
the people on the right would say,
well,
that's easy.
It's like don't sleep around and,
and get married and have sex with your
marital partner and that solve the
problem.
So there's strictures on sexual behavior
and those would be the traditional ones.
And what you see on the left is that
there's this weird paradoxical demand,
let's say,
um,
that people should be allowed to express
their sexuality in any manner that they
choose whenever they want,
but that sex is so dangerous that it has
to be carefully regulated at every
single stage of the interaction.
And so,
you know,
that many state legislatures have now
followed the example of university
campuses and put it in affirmative
consent legislation so that every move
you make towards physical intimacy has
to be proceeded by the instantiation of
a verbal contract.
Essentially.
It's like,
well,
can I take your hand?
Yes,
you actually hit,
from what I understand,
you actually have to say yes,
like nodding is not sufficient.
And so,
and so each stage has to be,
has to be proceeded by affirmative
consent and uh,
you know,
which,
well,
I won't,
I won't say anything about,
yeah,
I will.
It's absurd.
It's absurd to assume that that's how
human intimate relationships are
supposed to proceed.
And then you have complicated laws
emerging that are part of that,
that,
for example,
this is the case in California as I
understand it,
is that you cannot give affirmative
consent if you're intoxicated.
Okay.
So you think about that,
it's like,
well what does that mean?
It means that like a lot of sex is
illegal.
Been illegal for a long time,
including marital,
marital,
yes.
That's the one that's next to me on my
honeymoon.
Okay,
well that is thinking it,
it's,
it seems,
it seems to me,
it seems to mean,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm not,
no,
I'm,
it seems to me,
to me in the California legislation that
if you have sex with your wife or
husband and either of you is
intoxicated,
then you're either one of you or both is
guilty of rape.
That's what it looks like to me.
Actually,
I was in a debate a few years ago at the
University of Virginia Law School and I
turned to my debate partner in his head.
So if what you're saying is right,
um,
two people can rate one another,
right?
She said yes.
And I thought,
Oh shit.
I mean,
how can that be?
That's the question.
Well,
okay,
so then I would say,
well it's interesting because I think
that a lot of this confusion has emerged
fundamentally as a consequence of the
birth control pill.
So you know,
cause you got to think situationally
before you think it theologically or
psychologically it's like,
it seems to me that the 20th century
will be remembered for the hydrogen
bomb,
the transistor and the birth control
pill.
And those are unbelievably radical
technological innovations and maybe the
most,
yeah,
but that's dependent on the transistor,
you know,
cause it spawned off with that.
So that,
that's
technological innovation that spawned
all that.
Of the three,
I would say the,
the birth control pill is probably the
bigger hydrogen bomb.
So,
and because it,
it changed the fundamental biological
nature of women and men and because it
gave women for the first time in
biological history,
the,
the option of choosing their,
the status.
And that's,
that's abs.
Well,
yes and no.
Like,
yes,
we like it,
but it,
it's not something that's come without a
tremendous w h it's come with your mind,
complexity.
A fellow can anything reading?
No,
no,
I haven't that,
well I'm not,
I'm not making it in your
case for the abolition of the birth
control pill by any stretch of the
imagination,
but I'm pointing at its complexity.
And so because one of the questions is,
well,
once you can regulate your reproductive
function,
what attitude should you have towards
sex?
And one answer might be the more of it
under the more varied circumstances,
the better because why not?
And I would say that was actually part
of the attitude that emerged in the
aftermath of the birth control pill in
the 1960s.
Right.
And it was,
it was a reasonable response in some
sense because it's such a cataclysmic
change that you don't know what it
implies.
Well,
what's the consequence of that?
first of all,
people aren't reliable enough to use
birth control in an entirely reliable
manner.
So even though it can work at near 100%
efficiency,
you have to take it extraordinarily
regularly and in a disciplined manner
for that to work.
And so,
um,
there was still the problem of unwanted
pregnancy,
let's say.
And then there was the problem of the
proliferation of sexual epidemics and
that culminated in aids,
which,
you know,
could have easily wiped all of us out
but didn't.
But there's other sexual epidemics that
could have had the same effect.
But we've,
we've been fortunate enough to escape
them.
And,
and then,
and then more recently there's been this
weird inversion,
especially on the radical left that
points to the reemergence of something
like a set of sexual taboos.
You know,
like,
I think the idea that sex is casual and
that it's a form of entertainment is,
I think it's an absolutely preposterous
idea.
I think that it's psychologically
shallow beyond belief to hold that as a
core,
uh,
proposition.
Because it forces you to,
first of all,
if,
if it's repetitive sex with multiple
partners,
it,
it forces you to treat people as if
they're interchangeable.
And I don't see how that's good for you
psychologically or for the people that
you're using interchangeably.
Um,
it,
it implies that you can divorce
sexuality from play,
from the desire for more,
for a relationship,
from emotional fragility,
from love,
from family,
from responsibility.
All of those things that are part and
parcel of every one.
And I don't think you can,
and I don't think people's experience
indicates that you can,
and especially on the emotional front.
And I think that's partly what's
driving.
And there was also a residual sense that
there's something about sex that's
fundamentally dangerous and maybe it's
dangerous emotionally and personally and
maybe it's dangerous socially and
psychologically,
which most certainly is because it's a
powerful force.
And the way the left is reacting to that
is by insisting that all forms of sexual
behavior are valid and,
and,
and that it's reasonable to manifest all
of them,
but that it's simultaneously so
dangerous that absolutely every aspect
of it has to be state regulated and in
an increasingly draconian form.
And so I think what needs to happen is
that the left and the right have to get
together and have a,
like a real discussion about what
constitutes felid sexual morality.
And that's the conversation you have to
have way before you worry about solving.
Like the abortion debate,
which you know,
is very divisive and very,
and very intractable.
Well,
one of the things we talked about
actually just last week on the podcast,
does this cover story in the Atlantic
about the sexual recession among young
people that despite the advent of the
birth control pill,
abortion is,
is going down.
Um,
uh,
there's a,
there's lexus,
there's blessing is going down.
Okay.
And what have you looked into that worry
about opinion on that?
Well,
if you raise the cost of something,
you'd decrease its prevalence.
You know,
and,
and I think that it's,
it seems to be,
you know,
dangerous nowadays.
Well,
I kind of think that it's also a
reflection of the same thing that
Bloomberg reported on just a few days
ago.
He said that across businesses,
men are thinking,
I'm not spending any time with a single
woman that isn't,
you know,
associated with me in some formal manner
like my wife,
I'm not going to do it.
I'm not going to mentor young women.
I'm not going to be in a room alone with
them.
I know I couldn't face career
annihilation.
And instantly they,
they're frightened of
the young women.
Now that was kate.
Julian said that's part of it.
But we can overexaggerate the part,
I mean,
anxiety and depression is going up
amongst,
uh,
both young men and young women.
A suicide is going up,
um,
that,
that there's,
it's not just a,
you know,
most people I think are not,
we're talking about an elite demographic
who is into the consent and political
correctness and work with the,
this is across the board and it's
global.
Um,
it's in,
it's happening even in Sweden,
it's really happening in Japan and
Japan.
Exactly.
So,
so,
and that speaks to,
and especially in Japan,
they have,
yeah.
People,
especially young men have given up on
intimacy and having sex is actually,
I mean,
that had too much trouble.
Sex robots.
Right.
Well,
right,
right.
Well,
hello question.
and there's pornography.
Yeah.
There's pornography,
basically zero risks when you allow for
pornography.
Three the,
that,
that the men and women will sort of
separate that from their actual cyclic.
Like maybe we were seeing a whole,
I guess,
collapse of intimacy.
Hmm.
Let alone sex.
And,
and,
and I don't think that's just explained
by the political nature.
Um,
so I'd be interested in your thoughts.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't know that,
I don't know the literature on the
decline in sexual activity well enough
to know if it's valid or reliable.
But I mean,
I think that,
you know,
in a stable society you take lots of
things for granted.
You take,
you take the fact that men and women are
going to be sexually attracted to one
another for granted.
And even though it's more fragile than
it appears.
No.
And it's suppressed more easily than you
might think.
Um,
and you take the idea that men and women
are going to move together towards the
establishment of longterm intimate
relationships for granted.
But that's partly because you don't
understand what invisible preconditions
exist to make that self evident,
you know?
And when those invisible preconditions
are disrupted by rapid technological or
sociological change,
then things shift underneath you when
you don't know why.
A lot of it is traced to the advent of
the smartphone,
especially in the generation z that,
that kate was explaining this to us,
that you could see it was broadband
internet and the smartphone that led to
this.
You know,
increasing fall off of relationships.
Maybe the abstract is more interesting
than right proximal.
Well you see that I just want to,
I want to know the truth.
Have you ever been with somebody who
would have loved,
if I'm fascinated and all that,
but
you really wanted to get back to your
smartphone.
Has that ever happened?
Yeah.
Well it happens all the time.
No Tab is during our podcast.
I tell you to put your phones.
I know I'm climbing.
I'm researching for the printers of the
pot.
Very addictive,
very addictive.
You know,
I read the other day that
um,
they're very laurie,
they are kind of going together.
The preferred method of interpersonal
communication between young people know
is texting rather than face to face
communication.
Right.
And the swiping the apes.
That's,
that's,
that's a very interesting topic to the,
the uh,
like the tinder phenomenon.
That's right.
Cause that that's an also right.
Major technological revolution.
Because what it's done,
I would say for the first time is reduce
the cost of rejection.
Two males,
two zero,
because it hides it.
You're the only people you ever hear
from our people who haven't rejected
you,
although,
although they,
true.
But,
but there was one man who had to make
300 he key actually tallied it.
Yeah.
You have to make 300 requests of swiping
right or whatever one replies.
So I think he had the sense of,
sure,
sure.
But it's massively attenuated and
observer.
You're not being humiliated.
Not at all.
It's really,
it's really at arm's length and you
know,
you can swipe very,
very rapidly and so you can get all that
rejection over within a very short
period of time.
It's like losing a video.
Gamers or well last be worse.
I mean not nearly as bad.
Yeah.
So,
and you know,
I,
I don't know what,
I mean,
tinder also reduces the,
one of the other things that,
things that you want to think about with
regards to sex,
and I think this is probably
particularly true for women,
is that to what degree is it in women's
interests to allow the cost of sex to
fall to zero?
Because with pornography certainly does
that.
And it just seems to me that that's not
a very good long term strategy for
relationships between men and women
because whatever sex is worth,
the cost of zero is the wrong price,
and so that's,
you know,
oh,
you heard of the bunny ranch and pay
quite a bit for it.
Well true,
true.
That's true.
But you,
you know,
you don't have to,
no.
You know,
I've heard from a number of women what
written read blog reports on their
frustration with their attempts to be
relatively sexually selective.
Like let's say they decide that they're
not going to sleep with their new
partner on the first date.
You know,
they're frustrated by the fact that to
the degree that they're being cautious
in their sexual behavior,
which I think is actually an admirable
idea,
that they're instantly out competed,
especially if their partners are
somewhat impulsive by women who will say
yes at the drop of a hat.
And so,
well,
again,
I don't think you know what depends on
what the goal is.
That's the thing is that there's the
short terms,
there's short term sexual gratification,
but the literature indicates that
married couples,
for example,
or couples in a permanent long term,
monogamous relationship or more sexually
satisfied than single people,
and maybe the single people have to be
parsed out into those who were sexually
successful and those who aren't.
But I suspect that wouldn't make that
much difference.
But whatever.
There's utility of relatively immediate
sexual gratification for whatever that's
worth and the adventurousness that goes
along with that.
Let's say the hunt and the excitement of
having a new partner and all of that,
and maybe even the danger that's
associated with that because people like
to have a little bit of danger in their
life.
But what's the goal?
It's like what do people want?
And I mean there's a great book called a
billion wicked thoughts that was written
by Google engineers.
And so it contains great psychology
because Google engineers don't care
about political correctness and they
just write down what they find.
They don't even notice that it's
politically incorrect.
Hence James Demora for example.
And what they found was that women use
pornography just as much as men,
but the pornography that women use is
verbal.
It's not even just stick.
And the pornographic novels essentially
follow the same extraordinarily standard
plot line to the degree that publishing
houses like Harlequin,
which was going to say it's the,
it's the bodice rippers that's right.
Right.
So in the Harlequin series,
you have,
you know,
the ones that were published like in the
1970s,
that are pretty tame.
There's a small,
big,
or they're pretty hot actually.
Well,
there's a variety.
They range from,
they range from rep,
weebly team to essentially to hardcore
pornography.
But the,
but,
uh,
the plots are quite similar and the plot
is,
um,
you know,
young,
relatively innocent woman finds
powerful,
interesting,
dangerous male tames him and then they
live happily ever after love.
Yeah.
And it's the beauty and the beast plot,
which is a fundamental
fuck,
is search for women on porn hub.
We discovered,
we did an episode on Porn was,
uh,
for women it was getting rape.
Wasn't that like the no lesbian aneurysm
or at least that was your port.
Yeah,
that was your search on me.
Oh,
okay.
I don't know.
I didn't like porn is going to the
William Sonoma store.
I know it is.
It is female.
All those pumps.
Oh,
the no longer philosopher,
Bill Maher one said that men and women
should never tell one another their
fantasies because when are outraged by
what we say and we're totally bored by
what they say.
And I thought like women have kind of
these scenarios and you know,
I don't know Unicorns,
I don't know what they're doing.
Storylines,
storylines and men are just like,
uh,
I don't want to say this to you,
but there's a lot of just close ups of
female body parts.
Yeah.
Well men are much more visually oriented
sexually and,
but now they're being shamed.
I mean,
now that it's called the male gaze and
so there's all of this sick.
Oh my God.
The sports illustrated is exploiting the
female it.
Yeah.
Baby men like it.
And I,
I'm,
I'm worried that now sort of the way in
the past,
um,
sexual sub,
you know,
gays were shamed.
We're now reversing it in shaming like
heterosexual.
Yes.
That's definitely,
remember we had the young woman who
complained about being whistled at and I
said,
don't worry,
it stops.
Yeah.
Um,
do we have a little bit of time for a
couple more topics with you?
Uh,
because one of the
things that just coming out of this
younger generation and you have a
chapter of it in your book,
which I wanted to finish what the line
that we were pursuing with sexual
behavior.
The question is what's the end game?
And this is what people have to ask
themselves is like one of the
corollaries to the female pornographic
romance is actually the establishment of
a longterm relationship.
And the question is,
you know,
it's so funny cause I got pilloried in
the New York Times,
um,
for,
for talking about enforced monogamy,
which is quite interesting because I
talked to,
again,
that gets brought up like in every,
it's so ridiculous.
I talked to that woman for two,
two days.
I know.
It was just like a little side comment.
And then that became like the like,
like enforced monogamy.
You mean forced marriage or,
no,
I mean that was an anthropological term,
which she knew perfectly well because
she's a very smart person.
Um,
and all it means is that there's a
pronounced proclivity in human societies
around the world to enforce monogamous
relationships at multiple levels of the
sociological hierarchy.
You'd do it culturally do you do with an
expectation you do it illegally,
you know,
an enforced monogamy.
So my son was just married and if he
came to me next year and he said,
you know,
hey dad,
guess what,
I've managed to have four affairs in the
last year with hot women and my wife
hasn't found out about any of them.
I'm not going to pat them on the back
and say,
good job kid,
you know,
I'm going to say,
what the hell is up with you?
You know,
you violated the vow that you took your
putting your whole future,
riskier,
betraying yourself and your wife.
Well that's enforced monogamy.
You know,
the,
uh,
the idea is that the social norm is the
establishment of a long term monogamous
relationship and that there are
strictures put in place to support that.
But also to punish deviation from it.
And you'd say,
well,
you know,
maybe,
maybe not so much on the punishment in,
but you could,
it depends.
It's like what do you want?
What,
what is it that you want?
You want a longterm stable relationship
or not.
And if that's the goal,
then your behavior should be devoted to
whatever it is that facilitates that
goal.
And I don't see that.
I certainly don't see that casual and
impulsive sex fits that bill now,
not in the least.
And all of the evidence with regards to
living together shows that that's
actually detrimental to the
establishment of a longterm
relationship.
So first of all,
common law marriage,
people who are in common law marriage
are much more likely to be be divorced.
So that's the first thing.
The second thing is people who live
together before they get married are
much more likely to be divorced after
they get married.
So the idea that while you can try
someone on for size and see how it works
and then you're going to see if you're
compatible,
it's like that's one story.
Another story is,
well,
how about you?
And I lived together for a little while
and you know,
if you're,
you're not so bad,
but maybe I can find someone better.
And if I do,
you know,
in the next year and a half or so
because we're not hooked together in any
formal way,
I can just trade you in.
It's okay,
you can do the same to me.
But I don't really see that as the sort
of complimentary mutual interaction that
leads to the formulation of long term
trust.
And I think it's a better story for
interpreting what constitutes living
together then.
Well,
you know,
we're going to try each other out
because that's what mature people would
do.
A store rental.
Yeah,
well that's right.
Wash the rental cars Reagan uses.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's it.
But what more,
most importantly,
the data indicate that it doesn't work
is that you're more likely to get
divorced,
not less likely because maybe the right
attitude is,
well,
you're probably about as flawed as me.
And you know,
we're lucky that we found each other.
And so let's see if we can make a
commitment because we're engaging in
something that's very risky,
you know,
an intimate relationship and we're going
to commit to each other and see if we
can build something of value across
time.
And there's a definite a risk in that.
But there's a compliment to your
partner.
It's like,
well,
I think you're worth making a sacrifice
for.
And what's the sacrifice?
Well,
it's everyone else.
It's a big sacrifice and there's,
and if you don't see that as a
compliment,
then I don't think you're thinking
because not only is it a compliment,
it's sort of like the ultimate
compliment.
And maybe you don't get to have a
marriage that works without that
compliment.
Maybe it's so difficult to establish a
longterm relationship that's functional
that you have to make a walloping
sacrifice very early on in the
relationship in order for that to even
be a possibility.
And you know,
maybe not because what the hell do we
know about what binds people together?
But,
but it's not that easy to stay with
someone for a long period of time.
You know,
it's,
it's a real,
it's a real commitment.
It takes a tremendous amount of effort.
Yeah.
But that actually you're bringing us
back to the beginning and that your time
with Tammy and um,
one of the things about,
I think,
I'm going to guess this is a bit of an
overlooked part in your chapter in your
book,
but I just was like one of my favorites.
It was your book on modern parenting.
No.
Yes.
And that was the goal and I thought I
would get most trouble for,
I know,
but it reminded,
it's don't read that far into the book.
Well,
well it,
it,
my mother,
when I had my first child gave me a
1950s copy of doctor spock and he was
considered so controversial and yet he's
just like the most sensible person may
new children very,
very well was a pediatrician.
And you,
your rule for parenting is do not let
your children do anything that makes you
dislike them.
And you kind of in that one chapter,
and it's not even one of your longest
chapters,
just did this wonderful sweeping
overview of modern parenting and the
problems.
And in some ways that we're producing
maybe some of these kids who are
prolonging adulthood,
prolonging the markers of adulthood,
um,
that,
that you feel that parents,
uh,
you said you see today's parents is
terrified by their children.
Not least because they've denied credit
for their role as benevolent and
necessary agents of discipline,
order and conventionality.
And then you told some hilarious stories
about when your wife ran a daycare
center out of your house and you would,
you would get into test of wills with
some of the two year olds.
But the tough man [inaudible] son is
ordinary.
I'm glad to hear he got married to Greg.
He still doesn't want to do anything he
doesn't want to do.
Yes,
very charming and very emotionally
stable.
So it's like he's easy to get along
with,
but trying to get him to do something he
doesn't want to do.
It's like he had my wife defeated when
he was nine months old and she's tough.
Like,
seriously,
she,
she's no pushover,
but he would just sit there with his
mouth closed and glare at her.
It's like I'm not eating out and I can
take more than you can dish out.
It was really something to see,
you know,
to see that kind of force of will and
someone not small.
Let's talk a little bit about that.
And just the modern roles between men
and women.
I mean we're less,
you know,
you don't really,
you're not really supposed to
distinguish between fathers and mothers
even though that seems to inevitably
happen in most [inaudible].
Well it happens in large part because
the children differentiate between them.
Like parents are under the delusion that
most of what you do with your children
is driven by what you want to do with
your children when in fact it's driven
to a massive degree by what your
children want you to do with them.
And so there were studies done 30 years
ago on feminist parents who decided that
they were going to raise their children
in non gender differentiated manners.
And when they were studied they found
that the parents who had that explicit
philosophy,
we're just as gender differentiated with
their children as the parents who didn't
have with the philosophy.
And the reason for that is that if
you're a parent that has any sense at
all,
you don't re respond to your children as
a rigid idiot log.
You respond to them as whatever it is.
The child man manifests himself,
him or herself as like,
you know,
with any individualized relationship,
you take your cue from the person and
you might think,
well a child has no intrinsic nature.
But you know,
if you think that you either don't have
children or you've never seen a child or
you're so blinded by your radiology that
you don't have a child,
you just have a blank projection screen
onto which you project your
presuppositions and then heaven help
your child.
You know?
Um,
so,
so a lot of the gender differentiation
is actually driven by the children's
demands and that's all for the good.
That chapter,
I thought I would get into tremendous
trouble for writing that chapter because
it's contentious right on the surface
just to the rule because the rule first
implies the children can be dislikable
and then I would say again,
you know,
like have you met children?
Exactly.
We have a very child where their
children,
you didn't like obviously,
and so lots of children or dislikable,
but it's taboo to admit that because
they're all sweetness and light and
innocence ever since Rousseau.
But you know,
we so put all five of his children in an
orphanage where they all died.
So maybe we won't.
So we won't talk too much about
Rousseau.
And um,
and then the next taboo is,
well,
that parents can dislike their children,
right?
But if you're a clinician and you don't
think that parents can dislike their
children,
then well then,
well then you're not a clinician because
one of the things you constantly see is
that pathology within families is an
incredibly con common source of
psychological destabilization,
right?
And it's terrible tension between
parents and their children in between
siblings.
What I suggest in the,
in the book,
which I think is radical by today's
standards,
is that your fundamental job as a parent
is to ensure that by the time your child
is four years old,
that they are maximally desirable to
other children and to adults.
Because what happens is that after the
age of four,
you aren't the primary agent of
socialization.
The social world becomes the primary
agent of socialization and if your child
is the sort of child that's invited to
play by other children because your
child is capable of for stolen
gratification and taking turns and
playing someone else's game when,
when it's necessary and abiding by the
rules and not having a temper tantrum
when they lose and not getting to,
you know,
high on their horse when they win,
then many children,
we'll invite them.
Sorry.
Oh wait,
wait.
I don't know what you mean.
Just say it.
What do you want me to know?
I,
I know we have,
we have our limited time and so I just
wanted to,
I was actually saying
any more.
This is great.
I was selfish of me because I really
wanted to hear you talking about,
I know.
I just want to let them all take 15
seconds to wrap that up and then stop.
Please.
Well.
So look,
you get married when you have your
children and you're flawed and your
partner's flawed and hopefully you're
flawed and different ways.
And so you put the two of you together
and you make one approximately normal
person and then hopefully,
and then your child has to interact with
that dyad.
That is a reasonable representative of
social norms.
And if they disappear,
if your child disappoints you with their
behavior,
the probability that they will
disappoint other people is very high.
And so you have an ethical obligation to
ensure that your child is behaving in a
manner that makes them optimally
desirable to their playmates and also to
other adults.
Because then the kids invite them to
play and they get to be socialized,
right?
They get,
they have friends for God's sake.
It's like,
what do you want for your kids?
How about some friends?
Wouldn't that be nice?
And maybe what you'd like is that they
regulate their behavior well enough so
that when you take them places,
restaurants to see your friends,
to see your relatives,
they behave in a manner that's
sufficiently civilized.
So their intrinsic charm wins over the
adults and everywhere they go,
people are smiling and welcoming instead
of wishing with fake smiles that the
damn Bruh would leave along with their
foolish parents,
which is not a good,
that's not a good environment to have
your child constantly exposed to no
friends because they're too selfish and
immature and irritated era irritating to
adults so that they're barely tolerated
under the mask of false smiles.
It's like you have an ethical obligation
to regulate your child's behavior so
that they're optimally acceptable
socially.
And that is not how people look at
children in the modern world.
They think,
well you raising their self esteem or
you're enhancing their creativity or you
don't want to put constraints on their
behavior because you're going to
interfere with the flowering of their
intrinsic self.
And you know,
it's all Bruce Soliah nonsense and,
and,
and there's no evidence that's rice.
Yeah.
Father,
yeah,
he was straight
am such a corrupt and he had these
babies with this poor scullery maid and
left them all in a actually a place
where they would just languish and die.
Yeah.
Right.
Five of them.
Rousseau.
Yeah,
no,
I know.
Yeah,
exactly.
Oh,
and Ben.
Ben Is intrinsically good.
Yeah.
What external?
Sean,
a few weeks ago I was reading about you
in and somehow I got onto somebody's
twitter feed whom I will not mention
because,
oh my God.
But anyway,
a difficult person and she was attacking
you and had a,
a selection from your book a bit where
you had called two-year-olds little
monsters.
And so suddenly all of these distraught
twitter followers of this feminist we're
saying,
ah,
called the monster.
Yeah.
Little monsters and nobody,
and then occasionally there'd be a
parent
who would take,
they kind of two year olds kind of our
monsters,
you know,
and then there'd be eh,
and they can kind of art and they had
taken this out of context and shown it
like just something to deplore in a bit.
And it was so amusing to me this little,
hopefully they will soon be cursed with
some too.
I won't tell say which one was two years
old.
Yeah.
Had,
he was a good boy,
but he had an insane meltdown in a
supermarket.
I was with my mother.
We both pretended we didn't know.
No,
I don't want to be the parent.
Oh yeah.
Watch.
And we heard people say,
oh my God,
look at that.
A child watching a two year old having a
Tantrum is,
it's so terrifying.
I didn't want to be associated with you.
The
boy who used to be like,
when my wife was taken care of more kids
than ours,
there was a little boy who,
who,
who had learned to throw a pretty decent
town and uh,
and he would do that and it didn't work
in our house because we just leave him,
have his tantrum and going into to a
different room and then he'd kind of
wake up out of it.
There wouldn't be anybody around.
And so that,
like if you put all that words audience,
dramatic display and you have zero
audios,
it's not,
you're not going to sustain it anyways.
He could actually turn,
hold his breath until he turned blue.
So you should try that.
You go home and see if you could do that
in front of the mirror man.
Like it's hard.
It's very,
very good.
You have to hire it will you do.
It was impressive.
It was.
And you know,
two year olds are very impressive.
They're there,
they have unbelievable of rage and
dis-inhibited emotion.
And your job is,
you know,
they're,
they're driven by these underlying
motivational systems that are
unbelievably powerful.
And it's part of what makes them
delightful because when they're happy,
they're insanely happy.
And when they're playful,
they're incredibly playful.
And so the positive end of them is,
is way exaggerated compared to,
you know,
a rather drab adult.
And,
and so it makes two year olds
extraordinarily interesting.
But the same is true on the negative
emotion side.
They're completely dysregulated and it's
really hard on them.
Like to have a two year old who isn't in
control of their emotions means that you
have a child who's developing central
personality,
you know,
their,
their ego,
for lack of a better word,
is constantly being swamped by these
powerful underlying emotional systems.
You know what it's like if you are
enraged for any period of time or if
you're engulfed by grief,
like it's exhausting.
It's,
it's,
it's demeaning and it's exhausting.
And it's the same with a little kid.
It's like it's a real defeat for the
developing integrated individual to be
subjugated by those catastrophic,
powerful emergency motions.
And part of your job as a parent is to
scaffold the part of the child that can
regulate and inhibit those powerful
underlying systems.
So with my son,
for example,
when he used to misbehave,
I would count,
let's say you're going to go sit on the
steps.
He'd say,
oh no I'm not.
I say,
Oh yes you are.
And then usually I'd have to chase him
around because he wouldn't go sit on the
steps.
And so I put him on the steps.
Say you're going to sit there until
you've got yourself under control.
And so he'd say,
no,
I not say yes you are.
And then he tried to get up and I just
told them,
say you're going to sit there,
I'm going to hold you until you sit
there.
No,
I'm not.
It's like I could out wait a two year
old.
So I usually won those battles and then
he'd sit there and I say,
look kid,
this is the deal.
Let's say two things,
like you want to have a bad day or you
want to have a good day,
you think about that because if you want
to have a good day,
no,
you can just have a better idea.
If you want to have a bad day,
we could have a bad days.
You sit here and as soon as you can
control yourself and you're ready to be
civilized than you can come back and we
can have a good day.
So He'd sit there just,
just,
it was unbelievable to watch.
Just the developed with rage,
you know,
just trying to get himself under
control,
you know?
And so I'd come back 30 seconds later
and I'd say,
you know,
but it's got yourself,
got your act together yet.
No,
no.
I wait.
And usually it took them two or three
minutes and he'd calm down and then he'd
come back out and you'd say,
I'm ready to have a good day.
And he meant it,
you know?
And I can tell he meant it too,
because whatever resentment I was
harboring towards him for his
misbehavior.
And you have to watch that when you're
an adult would vanish because he'd come
and he'd,
he was done.
He was ready,
just,
you know,
to proceed on a civilized basis.
And it was really interesting to watch
that because it took him every time he
sat on the steps,
it took them a shorter and shorter
period of time to attain mastery.
Right.
Until,
you know,
it got to the point where he could only
have to sit for 15 seconds or so when he
would bring himself under control.
And that was a victory.
Like you,
if you imagine the neurological systems
develop that are responsible for
personality integration,
it was a victory for those systems
because they were attaining the ability
to regulate the lower order,
spontaneous emotions and you know,
and,
and he,
he turned into an individual who's
capable of a tremendous level of self
control and you know,
when he had
large gaming with,
yes,
absolutely.
And,
and while it didn't turned out well for
my daughter to be,
cause she ended up being very ill and he
ended up being extraordinarily
levelheaded,
dead reliable,
and thank God for that.
Could you,
could you come to my house and do that
for my little multiple izzy?
Because I can't,
I can't,
I can't eat.
I can't train her.
She's like a woman and ice.
The next book a dog.
I would love to have rules on how to
train your dog.
You like cats.
What?
I,
that's the one role I objected to like
what's with petting the cat.
I wrote about dogs for two pages to
begin with,
just to satisfy the dog that didn't
satisfy.
They're not,
they got a score.
You can't satisfy them.
No.
Right.
Well,
we can't thank you enough for coming
here.
Um,
I know the Aei audience is just so
delighted to have had the chance to hear
you.
Well.
I'm really personally got the chance to
talk.
I've only met you once.
We met in DC,
but I've just seen you pass the
electronics.
Yes.
Oh,
you've swiped past.
Oh yeah.
Well,
there was that.
We're not going into that.
Okay.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
Thank you Jordan.